on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
j'ai bougé d'un petit essai du rhin
c'est belmondo qui vous a fait attention
il ya lu anaky à la maison et mon
attention tu à bouger jean guéhenno bien
alors interview l'arthrose facile et je
vous préférez draguer ou faire draguer
mais c'est souvent le contraire qui se
passe
mais pourquoi personne voudrait que
c'est obligé de breguet c'est pourquoi
ils ont peur de ce pont de l'est où ils
ont peur d'isabelle alonso
je vous le dis j'en fais partie on est
complexé et c'est vrai parce qu'ils
avaient mal tourné
si vous étiez ici qu'elle est jolie
saint procès alonso elle vous a tout cas
même si elle peut vous colle un procès
non retient déjà sur les latéraux on est
sûr d'avoir un prêt c'est bien un jeu
préféré larguer ou faire larguer vous
préféré embrasser ou faire embrasser 2
les deux préférés caresser ou faire
caresser
ça dépend des noms tout est possible
alors important est ce que vous avez
besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour de
faire l'amour pourrait mais j'ai besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour mais mais
faire l'amour peut m'aider à aimer un et
vous lui enseignez comment s'est elle se
disait je suis tranquille et on y va à
la question vous avez besoin d'aimer
pour faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour
pour aimer un truc des si en fait
amoureuse pour faire l'amour ça y'a
aucun de tous il faut un très beau je
suis pas sûr
c'est à dire faire l'amour et apprendre
amoureuse non peut être un peu amoureuse
donc même pas oui oui d'accord mais
c'est l'inversé garçons au moins 24
heures dans les garçons les garçons il
faut qu' il faut qu'ils fassent l'amour
pour aimé e
oui on est très différent voilà donc il
faudrait pourquoi c'est difficile vient
alors le lieu idéal pour faire l'amour
je ne dirais pas un lieu je dirais
plutôt une ambiance des bougies ah oui
dans les églises
enfin un peu sombre mais pas trop ouais
c'est ça va justement je vais vous
demander si vous préfériez la lumière
est un tout allumer donc des noms voilà
clair obscur et vous ont plu sur scène
non je m'offre à mon public au clair de
lune au clair de l'huma très important
aussi le lieu où vous seriez incapable
de faire l'amour sont des néons et sous
des néons
c'est vraiment une question d'éclairage
à quoi ça tient finalement vous préférez
un mec qui bosse bien avec un fidèle ou
un mec qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle
préparez-vous folie ça va tomber sur
vous un garçon qui sait bien l'amour oui
parce que sinon ce serait moi qui serais
obligé d'être aussi des bas à vous non
non non non non non non qu'il sera
infidèle temple 24 heures sur 24 ça ne
dérougit pas à ce que j'aime pas que ce
soit un feeder non pas du tout
présentation n'appartient à personne et
personne ne nous appartient donc
s'éclaircir
on s'orienterait françois les henry et
les tentations et quelques quelque part
on a beau faire ce qu'on veut et comme
je ne crois pas du tout à un sentiment
qui est très moche qui s'appelle la
jalousie je ne crois pas du tout à ce
sentiment là donc voilà non je ne pense
pas que paul soit d'accord mais c'est de
l'arnaqué pas la gorge mais il est très
d'accord j'en fais le coup apple et non
mais sincèrement je pense qu'il faut
croire la civilité et voilà c'est sexy
la fidélité bien sûr fort de près quand
même pas me fais des trucs insensés il
faudrait jamais avec une rencontre d'un
soir à savais pas ça dépend de vrais
l'imaginaire de chacun
alors on les dit quelque chose une dire
que je suis atterré les 6000 dégoûté par
ce qui n'est pas le fait résumé la
situation on sait que thierry nous a
posé une question tout à fait autres aux
filles qu'il a pensé à olemps là comment
il résume à ce qu'ils voient là donc
c'est c'est pas juste on n'a pas eu la
même qu'elle a également traité de
[ __ ] alors dans le couple vous pensez
qu'il faut tout savoir ou rien se dire
pas tous à dire pas tout se dire ah oui
est-ce que embrassait s'est trompé sur
monteront plus avec le carcan que tout
sexe - m'éclate est déjà non et est-ce
que sucer c'est tromper mais je sais pas
je veux m'en mets pas joué en tout cas
oui un peu quand pis il me disait que
non